Hey look at that some people who aren't
completely tired of my face yet that's
nice it's nice to have you here um usual
angle in everything but I did change the
setup a little bit so I'm not having to
look all the way over there to see the
chat now I just look down look back up
and hopefully I'll be a little bit more
connected to all the goings-on just get
this up and hey there we go
how's everybody doing it's it's tough I
know it's tough and it's gonna be tough
for a while but we're gonna have some
fun tonight
so I tried to cover the plan as much as
I could in the title of this thing but
we're gonna do a Q&A and this will be
the second time I've done a Q&A Wow
actively drinking not just talking you
know the usual water but so here's how
this is gonna work last time last time I
did this the way it worked was super
chats of a certain amount or more would
get me to take a shot now last time I
did this I had the amount set at five
dollars not trying to milk funds out of
anybody but that was too cheap and you
folks really got me hammered pretty
quick so this time I'm making it ten
dollars any super chat of ten dollars or
more I will take a shot out of my new
Heisenberg shot glass which Liz got me
for my birthday so that's the plan as
far as that goes I will be looking at
questions otherwise you don't have to do
the super chat in order to get me to do
a question although if you include a
question with the super chat that
guarantees I will answer it so ah I will
kick it off with
one just to get the mood going but then
after that whoops already dropping
things that's not good after that it
will be shots on on super chats am I
wearing padding you mean my chest uh no
that's me not bad huh
so Cheers all oh that's nice
all righty what's the booze I'm going
light which I also did last time this is
butter shots
it is butterscotch schnapps when I say
light I mean it's not heavy proof this
is 30 proof I'm not doing like I've got
90 proof rum downstairs I'm not doing
multiple shots of that so and that was
the other thing I stack the deck in my
favor last time I did this I did
peppermint schnapps but you people kept
hitting me so often that it still it
went you know went down here downhill
quickly how are you doing on their
isolation rules I'm doing all right it's
you know it's not an ideal situation
it's it's hard to find my rhythm you
know when I'm stuck in the house and
that's not really getting broken up but
like the thing is like I'm not doing
great but I know the degree to which
things are tough for me or like way
lower than about 90% of just the people
I know so I'm not really gonna complain
let's see I'm the worst fan ever with
everything going on and having mailed
your birthday gift yet I'll accept it at
any point in the year happily so you
know are you planning on getting any
more source for your collection not real
ones I mentioned this a couple of
livestreams ago I think I've I've kind
of outgrown the impulse to get I like
the ones I have don't get me wrong but
I've kind of
the impulse like at this point I'd be
I'd be much more interested in getting
like foam weapons things that I could
like really just mess around and have
fun with and like take to conventions or
things like that and not have them have
to have them like zip tied into a
holster so they can't be drawn out which
is what happens like I took it's up here
I took this this baby to a Ren Faire as
a prop and that's all I was ever going
to be but they had to they had to
basically zip tie that to some bits of
this to ensure that this couldn't be
drawn so um you know I think that's kind
of that part of way sort of like when I
think about things to get I tend to
think the the foam Oh weapons some of
which are on my wish list to give you an
idea of what I'm talking about there I'm
actually loving self-isolation
I'm warm already I had to take this off
well I'm glad you're loving it it's I
will to keep blasting for a while
phone weapons to practice do love the
face with the fam I'm the only Star Wars
fan out of the members of my family who
would be physically capable of
recreating that so probably not I'm
watching this on my phone on Chrome and
on the desktop version it's an absolute
hellscape for my phone help I you did
that to yourself my friend excuse me
any cases for a new detective character
I'm working on to solve no not without
my head like you've really got to build
those things meticulously if the point
is the case like you can do some
detective stories where the point is
more the interactions or the point is
more the personal journey of your
detective character but if you are
really zeroing in on the crime being
solved you've got to build that stuff
like clockwork and I'm sure a sec I'm
not gonna do that off the top of my head
a while starting to
I'm considered an essential worker so I
haven't been home too much um I'm sort
of in a weird place as far as that goes
because I like technically speaking I'm
not an essential worker I'm in sales but
the company I work for is classified as
an essential company because we make and
distribute and sell for staid products
so the only strictly speaking essential
workers are the ones actually building
and shipping the stuff all the office
workers were sent home but we are still
working we're working from home because
while I may not present be an essential
worker my company is and my company's
still up and running so I'm still
putting in full work days from home
that's where I am as far as that goes
interested in the new Batman film I need
a trailer
honestly like these random images the
Batmobile it looks pretty cool other
than that like I've got nothing to go on
really other than the cast in most casts
can go either direction depending on the
script they're working with or the how
the director does it not matter Reeves
is a decent director so I mean that
helps but we'll see how would you feel
like the doctor regenerated to a
teenager I would feel like that would be
a pretty hokey gimmick and and they
would be very hard-pressed to find any
teenager who could bring the sense of
gravitas that you would need to the
doctor so I I'm not gonna say this one I
had to present impossible for it to work
but I would not recommend it oh also
you're not supposed to be asking me the
Doctor Who question Oh
channel bub hey how you doing uh been
away for this channel for a few months
what's been going on the last few month
this channel and your other one well
I've got well actually technically I
have four channels but I basically got
three main ones that I update I've got
this one I've got the very while then
I've got the break room so you know
still keeping up with the usual thing oh
hey Teresa ha ha ha oh it's good to see
familiar names and everything Tom
Holland is no longer a teenager if
you're
like no we're not doing Doctor Who
questions stop getting me down there
okay here we go what I'm coming
what upcoming movie would you be willing
to sneak away from the house to watch in
a theater well the the the true answer
to that is none because I I help my
mother out a lot and I have to help her
during this and she is old enough and in
the danger zone that there is literally
no movie that I would sneak out for and
it's also moot because all movies are
too late anyway but to sort of engage a
bit more with the question which I'm
assuming the premise is a bit if movies
weren't being delayed indefinitely and
we were still getting the schedule what
would I in theory if I didn't have to
worry about someone sneak out to go see
well okay give me a second I'm trying to
remember what was scheduled to come out
hmm tiny bit of that down the wrong pipe
in the next I get pop um in the next few
months I mean I wanted to see Black
Widow not that I thought I would have
broken quarantine to do it
I'm certainly having a hard time
thinking about what the heck else was
coming out over the summer like the
other stuff that's further down the line
I'm still waiting like I'm curious about
the Eternals but I kind of need to see a
trailer on that so I'm not sure there is
anything coming up there there was some
really a ton this year that I'm like
super yeah about and I I don't know it
feels like a lot of stuff wrapped up
recently and you know both TV and film
you know Game of Thrones wrapped up the
Infinity war saga
wrapped up and I'm just kind of I don't
know it feels a bit like like a breath
of relief it feels like when I was
things to slow down a little sort of
years even more so now Mulan was coming
out this week yeah I was actually open
to seeing Mulan I wasn't gonna home
about it but I was I was open to seeing
it stop being so cute love your videos
keep it up
uh-huh I shan't and I will in that order
everything is over yeah it was all gonna
be over eventually
have you seen parasite yet no no I still
haven't uh are you really forward to
anything announced for the MCU I mean at
this point I'm kind of um most curious
about the Disney Plus movies like Wan
Division and the what-if and Loki um but
like I'm I want to see what they do with
the movies like I said I still want to
see Black Widow what is your name I only
know you as council of geeks and I feel
like I watch a lot of your videos well
you clearly don't watch through the
credits cuz my name actually shows up at
the end in the credits every single time
my name is Nathaniel under most
circumstances if you go to one of my
other channels or if you see me perform
burlesque which is the thing I also do
the other name that I sometimes go by is
Veera um why no Doctor Who the reason no
dalliance with that one the reason no
Doctor Who is because questions about my
opinion on Doctor Who pretty much
dominate nearly every live stream and
definitely every Q&A I've ever done and
I would just like to talk about
something else
it's not cuz I'm like sick of Doctor Who
it's just like you guys got any other
questions besides that especially
considering a lot of them end up getting
repeated stream over stream over stream
and again I'm not mad about that but
like let's let's shift thoughts on Sam
as male rebooting Battlestar Galactica
didn't even know that was happening
still haven't watched either version of
Battlestar Galactica I've got no skin in
that game coffee or tea usually tea if I
drink coffee it's only once in the
morning
but I think t way more often favorite
musical theater actors ooh huh
you think I should have some as a bit of
as a bit of a theater nerd but I'm not
I'm not sure I do um you know there are
shows that I like and there's certainly
great musical theater actors but there I
haven't seen enough live theater with
people who have seen a more than one
thing and I wouldn't latch on to them
based solely off like soundtrack albums
so I don't actually have an answer to
that sorry I feel like it's hard to
watch Marvel movies now because the snap
is something that should be so much more
impactful and it's weird how they brush
it off I I'm not sure they brushed it
off I think they made it about as
impactful as they could without it
literally dominating every single thing
that comes out forevermore
which realistically is what would happen
but you know realistic is boring it in
case like that gets you stuck in in a
spiral who's telling the same stuff to
of the Daleks mean count as Doctor Who
discussion no go ahead go nuts wonder if
people feel like Drusilla staring at the
ceiling see stars well an isolation haha
what it a car a kid cool thank you
what is a show TV movie or TV series
that you made it through without being
convinced you enjoyed it um I'm not sure
there's any that I made it all the way
through um huh like there are some that
went off the rails but I stuck with them
even as that happened United States of
Tara comes to mind third season really
went to heck
there was this I I watched two seasons
of Big Love and I know it had more after
that but I just I couldn't stick with it
similar with orphan black I did I think
three and a half seasons of Worf and
black and I was like and
during that whole time I was like I keep
waiting to see if I actually like this
and it just never so like stuff like
that if it kept going eventually I did
bow out having belated birthday finally
do paid rent - oh thank you Amanda
so that's three favorite Joker I'll be
super specific my favorite Joker is Mark
Hamill doing return of the Joker the
Batman Beyond movie I like Mark Hamill's
Joker in general but there is something
just a little bit darker about that
particular story and how that juggler is
being used it's not like it's a totally
different Joker from how he'd been in
the Batman animated series up to that
point is very consistent but I feel like
with that one we got the darkness from
the character that earlier stories had
hinted at but hadn't really done a
proper dive into he's oh man oh that
story is so good and I did I I will
always love Terry McGinnis laughing at
him and pissing the Joker off thing what
I thought the Joker always wanted to be
Batman laughs but he just gets so angry
starts hurling grenades you're not
Batman
oh man that was good I don't watch that
movie again that's a good movie what
joke what Joker did would have messed me
up if I saw it when I was a kid well
like I was 1819 when that came out so
like I was totally down for it but yeah
it's messed up it's really messed up if
everyone who watched you semi-regularly
was subscribed do you know how many
subscribers you've had you would have um
honestly I'm not entirely sure no
questions just want to say hi a happy
belated birthday Thank You Tracy and
also thank you pop so here's the thing
most of my
videos do not have views in excess of my
subscriber numbers so I actually at
present not everyone who subscribes to
me watches actually most of my videos so
like for me a good video videos is doing
well is anything that is over 10,000
views and that's a quarter of my
subscribers so I've only had one video
this year so far have views in excess of
my subscriber count what you drinkin I
am drinking butter shots oh that that's
that for is somebody keeping track cuz
I'm not sure I am ah let's see who is
your favorite Harry Potter character ah
that is a tough call I tend to go back
and forth between Hagrid and the twins
part of the reason I go back and forth
on that is I feel like Hagrid is so
gloriously prominent in the first three
books and the fourth one they still
found some decent stuff for him to do by
the fifth one they didn't really know I
say babe JK Rowling didn't really have
as much for him to actively do so he
kind of tapers off which is unfortunate
where's the twins their prominence kind
of builds throughout I'm peaking with
the fifth book but yeah that's kind of
worth
are you a fan of Barry Manilow no not
really
like I don't know if you were going for
uh for a Buffyverse reference with that
that's where my brain went so I'm gonna
assume you did don't dissuade me I like
that idea
ah are you on estrogen if not how did
your chest develop so well so what I
have been on for the past three years is
I'm on spur lactone which is a
testosterone blocker now here's the
thing the amount of chest development
that I've had on sport lack of tone
alone without adding estrogen is
actually a typical breast growth Wow on
estrogen is pretty common the degree to
it varies spurt a lactone it it's not
impossible that you can get breast
growth on it but it's not common it's
certainly not common to this degree so I
actually had an abnormal amount of
growth off the thing that I was on
because strictly speaking spurt lactone
does not encourage breast development
but when you start blocking your
testosterone what happens is
testosterone is as a hormone is one of
the things that tells your body that
this area is supposed to be muscle
instead of fat so when you start
blocking testosterone you start blocking
that instruction so then this can become
fatty deposits as opposed to muscular
pecs and so losing definition in the
chest while in Smyrna lactone is not
uncommon but again the degree of growth
that I experienced on that alone is not
typical but it is what happened I'm okay
with it Thank You Castillo oh boy my
favorite Joker moment was his last
laughing masks of the phantasm
oh that's a good oh that's a good laugh
good pick I should also add was my first
Batman movie when I was four whoo that's
a little bit of a harsh movie when
you're four when when what is his name
Saul gets spun around for the first time
he's a big frozen grin who my favorite
Batman movie ever more so than Dark
Knight that is a legit opinion even
without nostalgia glasses that is a
legitimate perspective and as a very
good movie put this back
did you see the farewell such a
well-made biopic no I'm not even
entirely sure I know what that is a
favorite or current favorite book my
favorite book goes back and forth
between the last unicorn and the
restaurant at the end of the universe
hmm step 5
thank that's fine it's fine to my
account um thoughts on Jack Nicholson
Joker he's good I feel like he doesn't
quite get um the recognition that he is
due in the wake of what Heath Ledger did
coz Heath Ledger definitely took it in a
direction to a level I don't think
anybody could have predicted but
Nicholson like gangland you know mob
boss Joker is a totally valid Joker
that's what Nicholson gave us and he
works he's quick like I honestly think
the only bad Joker the only Joker that
does not work at least in terms of film
is is Jared Leto's it just doesn't work
it's not coherent it's just a it's just
a cluster of crazy fact ations jumbled
together there's no method behind it I
don't mean like method acting I mean
like there's there's no unify a
perspective determining how that
character behaves and you can try and
argue well the Joker isn't supposed to
have one well maybe not but the actor
needs to have one otherwise there's no
coherence to the performance so yeah
that that's the only one that I think
was not good I think every other version
of the Joker that I have seen works for
what it is being Cesar Romero is the
Clown Prince of Crime he's in it for the
fun it works Nicholson the mob boss
Joker it works Heath Ledger agent of
chaos it works
Mark Hamill holy crap yeah that works
and most of the other
is roland emmerich the german michaelbay
no wrong roland emmerich isn't
nihilistic enough to be Michael Bay um
you know the the various Joker's that
we've had in other films like under the
Red Hood and The Dark Knight Returns
adaptation I don't love but they're
still fine
sure Jack's should jacksFilms play agent
smith in the next Matrix movie I don't
know who that is so I don't know
do you like musicals oh yeah yes I do
um it's hard to find good ones but I do
enjoy musicals especially if there is a
character who sings in my vocal range
which doesn't happen with a lot of leads
cuz I'm I'm a baritone and most leaves
are tenors so they tend to go up and out
of my range so you know phantom of the
paradise and all that jazz are my
favorite musicals choices i watch the
film adaptation of cats and it genuinely
baffled and upset me I have no intention
of watching that one unless somebody
pays me I thought something idea of
another Bill and Ted I'm curious like
partly because the idea of doing a
sequel in the first place was ridiculous
and what they did was insane and also
kind of brilliant now it's been so long
since Bill and Ted's bogus journey I'm
not necessarily gonna hold out hope for
that but franchise has already set a
precedent of really bonkers sequels so
I'm game what do you think about the
latest Joker movie I'm not a huge fan of
it but none of that has to do with
Joaquin Phoenix's performance Joaquin
Phoenix worked his ass off and that is
all up on screen and all the props to
him the movie as a whole I didn't
particularly
care for ever thought of playing Sweeney
Todd I would love to play Sweeney Todd
see how what Miyazaki movie would you
show someone who doesn't like and isn't
really interested in Miyazaki all right
I'm gonna add that to the donation you
did earlier and call it ten so this
makes it six yeah I'm feeling that a
little bit
um so Miyazaki for someone who doesn't
think they'd like Miyazaki I would go
with Princess Mononoke cuz I think it's
it's the one that comes the closest to
having particularly if they're used to
Western entertainments that it comes the
closest to a fairly standard ish plot
that is more relatable because it it's
dealing much less with whimsy it doesn't
really have you know it feels more like
a fantasy epic that I feel like people
who aren't necessarily into anime or
don't think me as like he's regular
output is for them might be able to grab
on to so that's the one I would
recommend um you don't know who
jacksFilms
is I watched you over two years and now
that I know you don't know who
jacksFilms is I can no longer in good
conscience stay subscribed I'll miss you
if Chris Columbus is Blom house fan a
smoothie ever came out would you watch
it was he at the director attached to
that
[Laughter]
I mean maybe out of morbid curiosity
like I never got into the nav do you
have a favorite musical what would your
dream role be to play in a musical okay
this actually is just water so I don't
know if I can name a single favorite
musical it tends to vary over time you
know what role
I really really want to play I want to
play dan from next to normal if you
don't know that play it is a musical
about a family dealing with mental
illness the the mother and the family
has a very difficult to manage mental
condition and Dan is her husband who
tries so hard to be the stabilizing
force for the family he is so desperate
to be that but it's not that he can't do
is that nobody can for what is going on
in his family no one person can be the
stabilizer for this so I find him
incredibly human and also these things
in my range so there's that I'm a trans
woman and I hope thank you Cleopatra I'm
trans Rome and I love your videos about
queer representation in media how do you
feel about trans woman of cop how do you
feel about how trans women of color are
represented in media I haven't done a
particularly alert
I can speak particularly deep dive into
trans women representation to at least
off the top my head parse the
differences in terms of how trans women
of color versus white trans women have
been portrayed in recent years what I
can tell you off the top of my head is
that orange is the new black is the only
has the only trans woman of color that I
can think of who wasn't a prostitute so
I would point that out right off the top
my head cuz that's a problem it's
already an issue that trans prostitutes
are kind of a cliche but I also feel
like if I'm seeing black or not even
necessarily black non-white trans women
in films or TV they have tended to be
hookers and that's not an anti sex thing
sex work is work legalize no God not
even legalize decriminalize it Siri
but you know as a depiction that's
that's not cool
witch tropes do you like to see in
fiction uh there's a few things I'm a
sucker for I must I am a sucker for a
well-constructed heist
I am a big sucker for games where we
learn about characters through how they
play so like I'm a really big fan of
poker scenes I'm a really big fan of you
know card games between adversaries
things like that I'm a I'm a big sucker
for my dream roles are man in chair and
Drowsy Chaperone
I don't know that show particularly well
the Baker in into the woods good call
Tevye in Fiddler on the Roof woohoo
ambitious Sweeney or Anthony and Sweeney
Todd and George in I don't know what
that abbreviation is for I find Anthony
to be very dull in Sweeney Todd if I'm
being completely honest actually I find
most characters who aren't Sweeney Todd
and mrs. Lovett to be a little bit on
the dull side some of the some of those
one or two scene characters can can sort
of raise themselves up Pirellis is a
good example of that but a lot of the
other ones they can be hard to stick in
the mind because I feel like Sweeney and
mrs. Lovett really suck the oxygen out
of the room I'm not sure that's on fault
I think that's by design in a lot of
ways but yeah there's that there's a
segment of 80s Twilight Zone I need to
dig up for you ooh I am curious calling
me intrigued Sunday in the park with
George thank you I wouldn't have guessed
that cuz I actually don't know that show
like I feel like I've mentioned
repeatedly that I want to be in Nexen
normal do people even know that show
like at all or am I just completely out
of my luck on that are you a fan of
Antonio Banderas
yeah usually change my mind I'm still
if I could make it through finding how
your shelf didn't go on forever I can
make it through this yeah I do have to
frame that shop pretty carefully don't I
did you watch Steven universe future
finale I don't watched any Steven
universe much to my shame Oh favorite
Toy Story films somebody asked that
earlier
um second one I actually would make
Anthony into an unintentional stalker
viable um Thank You Matthew
much appreciated thoughts on the movie
Donnie Darko my feelings are is pretty
mixed I've not rewatched it in probably
15 years are my thoughts at the time
being it was interesting that was about
oh geez that was about all I had to
think about it I friends who were
obsessed with it but will you be going
to see Mulan in theaters well it has to
actually come out huh you know so I
don't know I saw a community production
of next normal last year oh cool so
somebody knows it
do you watch any D&D shows no I do
listen to one podcast I listen to
improvised weapons which my friend John
Van Luling is on AH playing playing the
dwarf cleric who has probably got to get
the party killed at some point I'm kind
of surprised he hasn't already if I'm
being completely honest let's see oh
hold on we're there were there burlesque
questions and I missed them somebody
bring them back up please I'm game for
that do you have any interest whatsoever
in the thick of it um I'm not sure I saw
in the loop and I liked in the loop a
lot I'm not sure I liked it enough to go
back and watch the show that built up to
it
have you seen The Witcher I have not
I've been binging on attack on Titan
have you seen it I watched three
episodes decide it wasn't for me
have you seen dairy girls nope favorite
spider-man villain ooh
that's a good question um best franchise
mythos folklore for Dragons ooh that's a
good question too
um do you watch RuPaul's Drag Race new
um so favorite spider-man villain best
mythos for Dragons um like I don't know
my first vitamin villain at this point
like when I was a teenager it was venom
cuz I was trendy it's like that um other
than that I'm not sure he's got a lot of
good ones do you dislike the TV Joker I
need to know which TV show you're
talking about because he's been on more
than more than one fan of RuPaul if so
have you seen the UK version my feelings
on RuPaul are like my feelings on most
drag and that is complicated I stopped
watching RuPaul's Drag I did four
seasons of RuPaul's Drag Race and I
stopped because I felt like more and
more and more the emphasis was being put
on the cattiness of the queens and that
was honestly reminding me too much of
why I moved away from drag and now favor
burlesque who has the best rogues
gallery um Batman probably but
spider-man is right up there flash has a
good one too what are some of your
favorite heist movies Oh God I mean
Ocean's eleven isn't easier I actually
also really liked ocean's 8 um there's
others like well like I consider at
least a segment of the first mission
impossible to be a heist movie um I'm
taking this cuz Cleopatra also hit me up
earlier for five so I'm pulling that
thing I go to make it ten let's keep
this going between the Netflix show you
and a new Joker film do you think mental
illness is being romanticized because I
do well I haven't seen you so I can't
speak to that one I don't know if we're
Manta sized is the term I would use I do
think mental illness has a tendency to
be leaned on as a writing crutch to get
away with
characterization that otherwise would be
called into question be like is that
actually a story that should be being
told and I feel like throwing up
mental illness is kind of used as a bit
of a bit of a shield and a bit of an
excuse to get away with some stuff I do
think in many words we're doing a little
bit better than you because they used to
be incredibly exploitative and still can
be let's be clear
in terms of people with mental illness
you know being serial killers or or
what-have-you
so like that's that's not a good thing
but I feel like we're drifting away from
that so while I feel like what's going
on right now probably isn't great I feel
like it's a notch better than where we
were so maybe we can keep heading in a
better direction kind of what's your
opinion on Dave Chappelle's trans joke
which one we just Benja locking key see
it thoughts have not so we don't have
thoughts but I have shots that was awful
is there any pop music in the last five
years you consider listenable or even
good
yeah like sporadic songs though like the
relationship I have with pop music is
I'll basically breeze through Spotify
going like skip skip skip skip ooh and
I'll find like one or two random things
I don't follow artists though for the
most part about the only artist who's
still current who is a pop artist who I
follows pink um that's kind of it though
other than that it's just like sporadic
one-offs here and there from various
artists when I was a child one of my
favorite shows was Kippur ever hear of
it because it's such a sweet show I have
not I should mention this YouTube video
the first five live performances of a
little priest from the original Broadway
Sweeney Todd production oh its priests
have a little priest
favorite trans or gender fluid character
in fiction mystique huh
Pincus tell current I think so I don't
know I still listen to her
have you seen Stu bag holds video on
thirteen reasons wife so what are your
thoughts on it yes I have and he poured
his heart into that that was a really
well-done piece I don't have really unup
inion on his opinion because I never
watched the show but he did are very
personal very well presented dive into
that show and what he thought they were
trying for and how they failed and his
issues with it he that was that was a
good good video uh mystique she was
nearly nightcrawlers dad I know I I when
I found out that what Chris Claremont
wanted to do was to have it canonically
confirm that mystique was partners with
destiny and then mystique fathered a
child with her when I found out that
Marvel wouldn't let him do that
ah for less Sweeney Todd oh I'd be so
down for that
would you prefer being a bird or a
pillow when going what huh
I'm missing burlesque questions oh for
God's sake um do you do you prefer being
a bird or a pillow when going out to get
car insurance
okay I heard a theory that tongs from
Harry Potter's gender-fluid I supported
100% here's the thing like if that's
your head cannon awesome I don't feel
like it's supported by the text she
would have the capability I'm sure but
we don't get enough of an inside look
into our mindset - for me to be
comfortable labeling our that that's
your head can I'm not gonna say you're
wrong he's just I don't make that leap I
say that as a gender-fluid person so
there you go
oh hey Joel favorite asexual rep in
media that is tougher because there
isn't a ton of explicit asexual
representation out there did you ever
watch a slight nning thoughts nope don't
know what that is
thoughts on the state of Star Wars
breather would be nice that's kind of it
do you like Wendy's restaurants yeah
they're all right now this TV universe
is done and you were stuck at home that
would be a good time to bend you right
now I'm just trying to UM to catch up on
on the stuff I'd already had planned
do you watch vouch she's a small
left-wing streamer nope I don't really
watch streaming which Lord of the Ring
books slash movie is your favorite first
one do you have any advice for someone
who wants to be a drag king but can't
travel for hours to get to a show and
lives in a tiny town I want to do shows
but don't want to go in public alone oh
trying to get involved in any kind of
specialized performance when there isn't
an outlet for it in your local area is
really really tough I am not entirely
sure what to tell you I think part of
its gonna depend on your own
inclinations and what the local vibe is
like be
because I don't know if it's a case for
you of drag Kings not being a thing
around you just because no one around
you does it or if it's not a thing
around you because the local populace
would be very unreceptive to it I don't
have a way of knowing which is the case
if it's the latter you're in very tough
straights if it's the former you can
maybe try looking into working with any
local performance spaces to see if they
can partner with a drag king troupe to
have them come in and try and network
that way I mean I give that as advice
but that's something that I myself am
very bad at I'm a crap networker so I
don't know that's that's that's tough
and that's really shame cuz I love drag
kings drag Kings are awesome and like
there's there there are some really
great ones up here in Vermont where I
live live long and prosper all y'all
wash your hands folks sorry tuned in
late I wanted to ask your impression on
the Batman I don't really have one yet I
need a trailer
Stewart deserves so much credit for
making a video that must have been so
difficult to make I'm either talking
about 13 reasons wise or his Fifty
Shades series I mean Stewart just does
great work and like most small youtubers
he's better than his viewer numbers
would indicate most pointless sequels oh
god I'd have to think about that there's
a lot
favorite spider-man film of the Tobey
Maguire hairspray rim film spider-man 2
that were like even a really a debate
have you seen Breaking Bad of course
I've seen Breaking Bad what would be
worse sitting through the cats movie or
Vogon poetry I mean I think I could get
away with laughing at the cats movie and
nobody would disintegrate
I think if I laughed if I tried to laugh
my way through Vogon poetry it would go
very badly for me switch from the matrix
was supposed to be a different sex in
either world yeah I saw that and you can
see where that that would have been very
much in keeping with a lot of the themes
of the film but yeah I guess Warner
Brothers put the kibosh on that have you
seen Brooklyn nine I have I'm several
seasons behind I'm behind on a lot
people it's so funny we feel like oh you
have extra time why don't you catch up
on this I'm like I have like 50 things
to catch up on crying out loud um best
wish is that this time thank you for all
your working insights thank you let's
see Kingsman ii was kind of not great
but Merlin's death scene was perfectly
heartbreaking
I kinda hate Kingsman too it's not a
point you see the wording of the
question I latched on to there's a
difference between a bad sequel and a
pointless sequel there was a point to
doing a Kingsman sequel cuz the entire
first one was about go to him up to be
ready to do these missions and he only
gets to do one at the very end so it's
totally a point to doing a sequel show
us more of this world he now is to be in
after all the training so there's a
point to Kingsman too it just sucked
like the ha the more I think about that
movie the angrier I get
it's so bad um but what I think
pointless sequels like honestly doing a
sequel to Rambo was pointless I'm not
sure the sequel the Rambo was even that
bad but it was pointless if you've seen
the originally why would you do that ad
makes no sense that's sort of where my
head goes trying to think more pointless
like there isn't a reason to do it in
the first place as opposed to you did it
badly ever seen the Arizona solution no
do you dye your own hair no no I don't
backing up
do you think better call Saul has
outdone Breaking Bad
better call Saul I haven't seen yet so I
couldn't tell you have you gotten the
car owner virus well I am paying off a
car loan so I think I may have caught
that one Highlander 2 does not exist oh
god yeah God the epitome of pointless
holy cow holy cow favorite Colin Firth
performance Oh
um honestly I think I might go with Love
Actually on that he's done a lot no
that's that's quite good speed to is
pretty pointless uh he yep
that's a good that's a good pick
favorite film of this year I haven't
seen a lot that's new this year uh hope
you're well boss your continued health
is in my best interest uh
Thank You Joel your your your concerns
so heartfelt for folks who don't know
Joel as my is my thumbnails guy and he
does get paid for that so let's see oh I
actually I should hop over to the
discord favorite Bowie film labyrinth
like I did yeah okay so over in the disc
or what have I got um I know wrestling
isn't your thing per se but from the
perspective of someone who doesn't watch
it what thoughts you have on
WrestleMania normally the biggest show
of the year being pre-taped and held
from multiple locations in light of the
pandemic I've seen a lot of opinions
from fellow fans that I'm highly curious
how this looks as someone who doesn't
watch the product I mean given that it's
a safety concern that to me strikes me
as the best way that they could do it
and actually still have the thing now
given what little I know about wrestling
and how much of it is very much
dependent on
feedback of the audience and the energy
of a live performance that maybe they
would have been better off just
cancelling the thing altogether because
that sort of presentation just sort of
saps out what is unique about the
experience of live wrestling but if
they're gonna do it I'm not trying to
they could have done in any other way if
you were to be sorted in any other house
than the one you're in which is
Slytherin for anyone who didn't know
which we do prefer if I wasn't a
Slytherin I'd probably be pretty content
as a Hufflepuff and you know just kick
back hang out in the kitchen it'd be
nice Love Never Dies was even more
pointless oh man I've never seen that
thing but I I know it exists who was
your first celebrity crush my first the
first one I remember really like hitting
me not even necessarily in the heart
hitting me in the nethers so to say was
when I saw hackers and Angelina Jolie in
hackers who homeboy it's a dumb movie
but damn it I love it I love it so much
it it's so stupid even at the time it
was stupid now it's really stupid but
man it's fun I enjoy that movie a lot
favorite Gene Wilder performance I mean
I think I gotta go Willy Wonka I don't
think that's his best movie best movie
of his that I've seen was Young
Frankenstein but for just his
performance and a microcosm Willy Wonka
microcosm boy I can use big words in
when I'm tipsy what's he's in Brooklyn
nine-nine you go on I'm not even sure
that's how I went back I'm not sure oh I
was just wondering what your thoughts on
kids the horror you returning soon I
never really got into that show so I
don't really have an opinion
have you seen fire fighting serenity
thoughts yes yes I did
umm I've got videos up on it I did a I
did a rewatch and I did a ranking so if
you dig through things I think is in the
Whedon verse playlist it's in there I've
done it shall we name a movie shall we
shall we name oh god it's moving uh okay
hold on shall we name movies that don't
it should never have a sequel the usual
suspects to the Spacey reprises his role
as verbal who blames Keyser Soze when
faced with allegation oh wow and oh like
that one hurts cuz the original usual so
tonight was one of my favorite movies of
all time and I have very much gone out
of my way do not rewatch it since all
the stuff about Kevin Spacey came out oh
you wound me ah let's see
Roald Dahl hated the Wonka movie yeah
but by most accounts Roald Dahl was a
bit of a bitter guy I'm just saying do
you play an instrument uh no when I was
in grade school I played the trumpet
well actually technically it was a
cornet that I played cuz I got my
grandfather gave me his um but it's
effectively a trump but it has a
slightly higher register because it's a
little bit smaller
um but I played that in grade school but
I haven't picked it up and forever I'm
not even sure I could still get a decent
sound out of it and I definitely don't
remember like notes and fingerings and
all the rest
oh boy that sounded that sounded dirtier
then I'm
- hahaha I am sober they lied did you
ever watch the movie the worst witch
it's a weird gender switch to Harry
Potter with Tim Curry hamming it up as a
major character I've heard of it I have
never seen it do you have any good D&D
stories to share
um I don't know how many of them are now
the Catalina on top of me I don't know
how many of them are good like what my
gaming group was thoughts on Daria I
liked her as a character the show I
could take her leave um when my gaming
group was meeting regularly I had the
notion I never went through with it I
never would have been able to pull it
off decently but I had the notion of
doing audio recordings of the gaming
sessions and releasing them as a podcast
and was gonna pop I was gonna call the
podcast damn it Paul because Paul was
our usual DM and he had a tendency to do
things that caused some or all of us to
go Oh have you seen mr. nobody what do
you think of a storytelling I've seen
mr. nobody and if so much of its plot
didn't hinge on basically the exact same
contrivance that Blanc hinged on I might
have liked it better but it still came
across as really pretentious to me III
see what it was going forward didn't
work for me but so like some of the
things that Paul would do if pop first
of all Paul had a tendency to create
NPCs that we desperately wanted to kill
and there would usually be one or two
members of the party who would go that's
it and just attack the NPC's or pole
with heaven in peace like after a run of
NPCs that will like jerk just around all
over the place Paul would introduce what
is supposed to be a completely you know
good positive force NPC and we'd
immediately
be suspicious cuz we didn't trust Paul
at all um
and he engaged in literal deus ex
machina in one story literally having a
god teleport us to where he wanted us to
be which you could say is the mark of a
bad DM but you know what the the fact
that none of us took any of the super
seriously we kind of all just rolled
with it God even the even the game we
did that Paul didn't DM which was a Star
Wars campaign that my friend Ryan ran
and Paul Paul came in couple sessions in
as a character called Maximo the Maximus
he was the galaxy's worst stand-up
comedian he would all he would somehow
keep getting booked but when he
performed there the audience would
usually riot
he was so irritating and I would I was I
was an astro droid for that campaign and
I was seriously trying to figure out how
I could eject him into space without
anyone realizing that I'd done it what
fictional version of space is most
likely in your opinion Star Wars Doctor
Who MCU um the Schnapp starting to kick
in
oh it's been kicked in I am kicked um
I mean look here's the thing I don't
think any of them are super likely
because here's the thing
we look at and allow me to get
philosophical with you we look at the
timeline of our own evolution as a
species we look at the
distances between galaxies and even
setting aside how far apart habitable
planets seem to be or at least habitable
to life as we understand it appear to be
in the first place even setting that
aside the distances and the time make
the notion of the sort of galactic
federations species intermingling doing
trade joining forces or fighting even is
incredibly unlikely I don't think the
notion of alien life is that difficult
to comprehend I don't think that I
should have intelligent alien life is
that difficult to comprehend but the
thing we have to remember is that the
distance and I think this is something
that it's something that science fiction
ignores rightfully but I think it's
something we tend to forget the
distances are so vast and the times are
so great that it is distinctly possible
for somewhere else in the universe for a
species on the planet to have evolved
risen gotten to a spacefaring point and
their own evolution and also died out
and have gone through that entire cycle
millions of years ago so you have the
improbability and it's not an
impossibility but the in probability of
life start up well the improbability of
other planets that can sustain life
there are some I don't doubt but even
among those not all of them will even if
they're capable of it so then you have
the improbability of life developing in
the first place then you have the
improbability of that life evolving to a
point of what we would consider sentient
then you have the improbability of that
life evolving to sentience and to reach
the technological
um degree necessary to get offworld and
for all of that to happen at a close
enough proximity to us that either we
could reach them or they could reach us
before the species just freakin dies out
and with all of those factors I think
the odds of not only us but any species
that is out there somewhere I'm sure
it's an infinite universe there's
somebody else out there but the odds of
any of us ever bumping into each other
are so phenomenally small that I the
odds are astronomical
is it possible sure incredibly
improbable though so until we get the
infinite improbability drive cobbled
together I'm not gonna be looking out
for flying saucers if you were to be
quarantined with the companion of let's
say a time-traveling soomi
time-traveling alien which one would it
be I will probably get along best
long-term with bill like short term like
going out for a night I'd want Donna but
I think if I was quarantined with Donna
she kill me after a while some planets
have so much mass that a species
wouldn't be able to leave its atmosphere
at all I mean that's another thing you
know and that's why I hedged my bets
with statements like life as we
understand it which it you know allows
me for the the opening of you know I
don't know buddy
none of us know all the possibilities of
what life could be but to the best that
we understand it you know uh have you
ever cosplay as anyone from the Whedon
verse I have not I'm not sure there's
anybody that I would to be honest I can
be cool to get that make up for the
vamping out done like that'd be cool but
that'd just be more of a curiosity than
anything else for me boy that was a deep
philosophical tangent I went on and the
tail end of this thing cuz I I do need
to wrap it up soon hey usual suspects
became my favorite movie as well but I
only wash
about a year ago before the news of us
BC came out at least you got more time
to love it
Oh fair enough trippy Donna's our
temperament a lot
I spoke to vote Saxon Oh seven he said
he'd quite happily do a collaboration
with you on YouTube he just hasn't been
asked yet
I don't know vote Saxon Oh sevens work
well enough off the top of my head and
like I'm generally open to
collaborations in general but like the
logistics are always a pain in the butt
like there are people who I've been in
contact with it I'm like let's do
something they're like yeah and then
just trying to figure out and make it
work is it's a nightmare most terrifying
film of all time invasion of the Body
Snatchers 1978 that is my answer forever
and always it's the only movie that
still messes with my head no matter how
much time has passed no matter how many
times I've seen it still gets inside my
head that friggin movie man have you
seen Dominic Nobles work yes of course I
get stuff it's good it's a little bit of
a shame he doesn't call himself the Dom
anymore but I get why he changed it I
get it but you know I had fun with that
name at the end of the video the Dom
would ask you to be his sub oh and a
more innocent time for him real thoughts
on Borges they taste like chicken do you
have a pet so if so what does it call
can you bring them on cam no I don't I
don't have a pet at present when's the
next bath talk all day I don't know what
I'll do that again I'd have fun but I I
don't know I need an answer to the
pillow bird question mr. geek I'm very
sorry but your question has been
rejected by the coherency filter please
ask a coherent question at a later time
can I call you mr. geek I'd kind of
rather you didn't
mr. geek is my father ah crap this uh
you seem like you to have a pet bird
really I don't know I guess what I think
youtubers were the pet birds I
immediately think of pushing up roses so
I don't know maybe my uh my opponent
comparison is off since you're wrapping
up our risk breakeven Oh doctor who rule
ah of course somebody who is going to
I've been interested in for years in
your channel only me fondly watch thank
you
oh well thank you favorite
time-traveling franchise other than
redacted oh right now probably heroes of
tomorrow I love pushing of roses yeah
what about a pet raven Oh see I couldn't
do it cuz rate it would be smarter than
me think you'd love the expanse grounded
sci-fi that has great characters include
a green LGBT and an exploration of
humanity after colonizing the solar
system I've heard good things about the
expense Master geek master well if
that's the way we're gonna go
funniest dubbed edits in anime you've
ever seen I don't know off da mad and he
plans for some videos on burlesque would
love to know how you come up with ideas
for a performance um probably not um
largely because I don't really know how
to talk about it um at least on here in
a way that would be appropriate for the
channel uh I mean
maybe uh maybe on the barrel while
channel at some point who are the other
people in the council geeks logo okay if
I'm from left to right Ryan
me Liz Paul oh and because this thing's
flipped I just did I just went I just
went the wrong way so Ryan me Liz Paul
that's what we got
Leo's questions seconded who are the
other people yet well there you go
I'm still getting over the bathtub talk
you showed a whole arm and some shoulder
think of the children
Oh scandalous I would say check out
these guns but I don't have any rest in
peace new fans don't remember the og
cast
I know it's fair like I haven't gotten
anybody else on this channel so far yet
this year and I feel awful about that
and now with the quarantine II like I
don't know when but hmm ah gonna wrap it
up with that one
the children person to flame no goodness
um I would just like to thank you for
exploring lgbtq+ representation and TV
because it solidifies my own warriors
and allows me to feel recognized oh
thank you I'm glad it I can help in some
way bathtubs
was the best video on your channel when
you know section called bath talks can
you recommend some nerdy youtubers who
aren't says have white guys I know
they're out there um yeah I can
recommend a couple pushing up roses is
now sort has sort of gotten into a
nostalgic media um last year's things
like Golden Girls and Murder She Wrote
and the goosebumps TV show but you can
go back further and she had a lot of
video game content especially adventure
games like old classic computer
adventure games that was really good um
shippers Guide to the galaxy has two
channels also has a comic books related
channel she's really good
she has eased off she doesn't upload as
regularly as she used to but she was
quite good um Jessie gender if you're
into Star Trek she goes deep into Star
Trek that's that's her that's her that's
her bag so she's good as well I think
those are the main ones for like nerdy
geeky that I'd I would point you to
oh if you dig D&D stuffer or talking
about writing at all you can check out
Stephen Partridge he he is sis white but
he's not hetero so you know bath time of
the Daleks what TV show did you stick
with the longest even though you weren't
enjoying it um was probably orphan black
I kept what I really wanted to like
orphan black but at the time that I
bowed out I realized I kept I will see
you out on the promise that it was maybe
gonna develop a point and it just never
did and it kept pissing me off
uh I'm not LGBTQ but I've got depression
and your videos have helped me distract
myself from things so thanks oh well
thank you and I wish you the best in
that I'm
I'm really fortunate that for all the
stuff that I've got going on in my life
that I don't have depression and like
honestly I would have been at risk for
it given some of the some of the things
in my family line and I'm lgbtq+ sorry
yeah not offended it's it's very tough
because I've had and have multiple
really important people in my life who
suffer from some degree or other of
depression so I've I have never had to
experience that fight myself but I've
certainly seen what it can do to people
who do have to struggle with that so if
my silly little videos are any kind of
help or consolation at all that's that's
really touching thank you thoughts on
walking dead I was gone after the first
season I bailed early
are there any musicals you can think of
that work and a non musical remake ah
not really because if a musical is any
good then you wouldn't want to take the
music out of it you know what I mean
like my brain started went to Blood
Brothers um for a minute but like even
that one even though the story doesn't
need to be done through song the nature
of the singing helps the very heightened
elements of that story go down better so
if it's a good musical than if honestly
it wouldn't work as well without the
music I mean that's that's what you do
when you tailor something to the medium
you're doing it with if the story would
work just as well without him without
the music and it's probably not a good
musical cuz you'd be going why are they
singing they don't need to me it's not
adding anything so you know
yeah I want to meet Ely - Blood Brothers
- yeah I mean I would still say even
with Blood Brothers while the structure
of the story doesn't require the music
there is a heightened element to it that
I think is easier to swallow in the form
of a musical you can take the story out
of the musical but you can't take the
musical out of the story that that
perhaps it would work for someone who
hadn't seen the musical well I mean I
guess if it's a story worth telling it
can probably be told without it but if
it was a story originally designed to be
told as a musical it won't be as good I
really think repo would be better as a
non-musical movie shut your mouth how
dare you
oh not okay not okay at all
repo would not work at all if it wasn't
Amy's gonna be a rock opera and the main
reason for that is because of the Opera
part that is what I love about repo the
Genetic Opera it is one of the best
examples I can think of that as a rock
opera where the emphasis is on opera not
rock and I don't just mean the fact that
they have opera style singing in it I
mean the story is operatic the story is
huge and overblown and these massive
massive terms of the story of these
ridiculous coincidences and these insane
connections and twists between
characters and familial relations and
emotion so heightened that the only
possible way to express that at a level
that does it any justice for the level
of absurdity that it is because that
movie is absurd is to belt it in the
form of song to the heavens that is the
only way to tell that story how dare you
hey
I fantasy or low fantasy um
I'm torn on that because I tend to like
high fantasy worlds and low fantasy
stories I would like a high fantasy
world telling a low fantasy style story
because what annoys me about how high
fantasy is they have a tendency to try
and build an epic story to match this
unique setting they've created and I am
bored about big stories I like small
stories in a big world so what will it
take to get why repo is awesome bit oh
it's on bullet I have a list of why it's
awesome topics it's on there I'll do it
at some point so help me
did you like we will rock you the
musical not just the song I don't know
it
do you like fantasy comedy like
disenchantment yeah I didn't get an
enjoyment out of it
I really do need to wrap up and now I've
got repo-man songs stuck in my head huh
side rate comes in a little glass file
the little glass file goes into the gun
like a battery duty to do okay
I can't keep singing cuz after how fast
the the box caught me reading something
that was copyrighted material I want to
run the risk that they're gonna shut
down the stream because I'm singing huh
anyway so that all addicted to the knife
yes see folks who have seen it get it
they get what I'm saying so thank you
everybody for tuning in I got a I got a
wrap it up I hope you all are staying
well you're staying safe and I I don't
know when the next stream will be it'll
probably be at the regularly scheduled
time which will be not this coming
Tuesday but the one after at a guess but
we'll figure it out this entire thing is
make it up as we go along but thank you
for joining me thank you for your
questions thank you for your donations
thank you for um keeping me in booze I'm
an adult how ridiculous is that so thank
you everybody be well and remember that
you are beautiful you are valid you are
loved you're the council I just run
these meetings and until next time I'm
good